after the second game one of my teammate
woke up to me and said you know this is
your last name NBA right you criticize
China you criticized Nike you're not
going to play basketball every game have
fun smile I hope you win a championship
but this is it for you just last summer
I am doing a basketball camp in New York
so after that we had an amazing
basketball here in Camp with the kids
after the basketball camp all the kids
just lined up for on me and they were
just getting pictures and taking uh you
know getting autographs one by one so I
remember so I took a picture with this
kid and his parents called me out in
front of everybody
the media was there my friends
um some of my you know other you know
athlete friends were there and little
kids were there he said how can you call
yourself a human right activist when
your Muslim brothers and sisters are
getting tortured and raped every day in
concentration camp in China
and I'm still smiling for the camera so
I took a picture with this kid I turned
around I was like I promise I'm gonna
get back to you
so that day I cancel everything I went
back to my hotel I started the study
about what's going on over there in
China
and the more I study the more I realized
wow
this is just crazy and no one have
encouraged to talk about this issue
you see uyghurs and the more you study
you see like Tibetans Hong kongers
Taiwanese people Mongolians falun gongs
they are all under heavy persecution by
Chinese governments
so I was like
well
I gotta talk about it but on internet
you can find all kind of news you don't
know which one to trust so bad it could
be a fake news it could be real news so
I call my manager I was like I need you
to find me a concentration camp Survivor
obviously he was very shocked what are
you talking about he said well just find
me one so he did find me when he was a
lady
so we sit down
had a conversation I had an amazing
one-hour conversation with her you know
um I wanted to just learn the story from
you know firsthand so she was telling me
about all the torture methods all the
gang raping all the you know Force
sterilization abortion and organ
harvesting and surveillance cameras and
I was like the more she talked the more
I was like sharing with myself I was
like I cannot believe the guy gave me
this huge platform and I only focused on
one dictatorship so I was like from now
on I'm gonna talk about everyday
theaters
damn so
I ended our conversation I asked her I
was like how can I help she said I don't
need your help I'm good I was like so
why do we have this one-hour
conversation for no reason like why did
you even come here
she said I live in America I live a good
life here I can do whatever I want I can
say whatever I can eat whatever I want
but help those people help those two
three million uyghurs or in
concentration camp in China because they
are getting tortured and rape every day
so at that moment I'm like I don't care
what kind of contract or endorsement
deal or anything you can offer me I'm
just gonna go out there and just expose
the whole system that's how it all
started and we know that the NBA has the
Chinese market is bigger than the
American Market exactly so this didn't
go down well
so like I said again I wanted to do it I
wanted to do it in a very unique way so
later on if someone comes and say why
are you doing this
I'm like this is human rights so you
don't you're telling me that you don't
care about human rights you know so I
wanted to do it in a very unique way
because I remember when I was a kid
whenever I watched an NBA game the first
thing I was watching was the shoes I
mean everyone loves shoes what color
they are what brand it is if they're
comfortable the next day I was telling
my dad please buy those shoes for me
yeah you know
so I had this
idea I was like let's reach out to these
artists around the world which
have been oppressed by their governments
because they are the one that knows the
story more than anyone
and um
and we're like let's tell them to put
all the struggles all this you know
emotion all the stories on the shoes and
we're going to go out there and play
basketball and these shoes are non-slip
neighbor I mean many of the shoes out
there in the world right now
unfortunately they have sweatshops on
the slave Labyrinth anyway so
we created the shoes
uh our for my first topic was Tibet free
Tibet you know it's not a political it's
literally a human rights issue
so I put the shoes on 50 bad shoes I
went out there and played basketball it
was right
I by my our first game I was playing for
the Celtics our first game against New
York Knicks
it was the opening night for the the New
York and it was just the whole world was
watching that game it's the biggest
rivalry so I put the shoes on I'm
warming up and a minute before the game
two gentlemen from the NBA
came to me and said take your shoes off
I was like excuse me
they're like well you know your shoes
has been getting so much attention
internationally you got to take them off
so
at that moment I was I was just getting
ready for my citizenship test in America
so I was I closed my eyes I'm like okay
we have 27 events missing America my
first time I've been freedom of speech I
told them no even if I get fined I'm not
taking them off they said we are not
talking about fire we're talking about
getting bad
which there is no rule against it
so that half I play zero minutes zero I
went back to my lock from I had
thousands of notifications in my phone I
clicked on the one that my manager sent
me he said every Celtics game is banned
in China
it took them 24 minutes first the first
quarter to the 12 minutes second quarter
20 uh 12 minutes 24 minutes depend every
Celtics game in television
so I was like well that clearly shows
the censorship and the dictatorship over
there anyway so after that game I played
zero minutes we lost the game and uh
after the game there was just huge media
starts literally every media in the
world from the very random countries
which I never even heard of want to have
an interview
I told my manager to decline them all I
don't want to have no interview with
anyone I didn't want my teammates to
think I'm doing this for attention I was
like decline everything and he was like
are you sure like decline everything
so after the game MBA called me
they're like well you know what you did
mbpa call me the player association
which I give thousands of dollars every
year to protect my rights against NBA
they say you cannot wear the shoes ever
again MB has been pressuring us I was
like am I breaking any rules they said
no they said well you cannot remember
again I was like if you're if I'm
breaking the rules tell me I won't wear
it
they pressure me so much I was like you
know what
fine I'm not going to wear 50 batches
every game there's a promise I said
promise so we hang out the phone so the
next game I wore free uh
so now that's what you call doubling
down so they call me after the game in
the second game they're like you're a
liar you lie to us we can never trust
you again I was like first of all relax
second I never lied to you I never said
I'm not gonna wear free legal shoes I
just said I'm just not gonna wear fritty
batches at that moment they got it they
were not going to be able to make me
apologize took my tweet down and say I
was not educated enough sorry whatever
so on uh after the second game one of my
teammates woke up to me and said you
know this is your last name NBA right
you're criticize China you criticize
Nike you're not going to play basketball
every game have fun smile I hope you win
a championship but this is it for you
wow that was it and that and it was as
simple as that simple as that
foreign